don't people use Saran Wrap excuse me
okay like so with the so you don't use
your debit card right because it's
direct access to the bag of chips yeah
when you eat chips you don't get the
whole bag just dump it all out and eat
three of them up I put the rest of it
back in use a credit card and that's
like dumping it out and then Saran
wrapping the rest of it ah I don't know
if that's a great one who eats like that
you eat like that yeah tell them dude I
opened the bag and I go through see
that's what normal people tell me do
that with your money I just think the
concept of Devon credit if you're gonna
use a bag of chips it's almost like that
somebody else brought a bag of chips of
the same flavor you get to eat that and
then when you know that you just replace
it see that's even smarter well I'm just
gonna direct compliment yeah that's a
great analysis relish the moment I know
thank you it's not gonna last long
please clip that yeah when I was like 18
or 19 like I was like why would I use my
debit card you also didn't have money
either I know but I don't want no one
stealing my 32 dollars I don't want no
one touching my overdrafted account
hahaha